hey guys how are you so you probably are
already well aware that ios 7 is out and
that's the new operating system for
apple's devices iphone ipad now they
haven't done a complete overhaul like
this since ever i mean this is really
this is really it i'm going to do a
little setup here for you on my ipad i
already did the one on my iphone and it
took volume two hours and for some
reason whenever i started my phone up it
was so slow i started freaking out and
i was very very sad but i did uh restart
and i closed out all my apps and so far
everything has been working pretty good
so we're gonna see how it goes for my
ipad so this is kind of a calm before
the storm because this friday new
iphones are out and so many of you guys
tweeted me that like justine are you
okay because you haven't made a video
talking about any of this yet so yes i
am okay i'm excited i will be getting i
think the gold 5s i'm not sure i'm
seriously so torn between getting the
whites or the gold maybe i'll do a
survey there's also a slate gray one but
all of my accessories are white so it's
kind of a toss up gold silver let me
know what you guys think anyway the
reason for this video is the new ios 7
is out and i'm super excited because
i've been wanting to do this all day but
i waited for you guys okay here we go
ready slide to unlock oh crap
i remember my password small victories
my friends update complete location
no i'm not enabling you kidding so the
interface is so clean like everything is
just
real freaking fresh here it is this is
the new interface
i think one of the cool things is like
the backgrounds like when you slightly
move this the background will kind of
adjust the accelerometer with your ipad
completely unnecessary but completely
pretty sweet i never put other
backgrounds i always use like the
standard issue apple backgrounds here's
the new settings look at that and look
at it it's so fresh and so clean and
everything here's all the new
backgrounds look at them let's just zoom
in even more
so this is the one that i have in my oh
look at this are so pretty i mean look
at it it's just shining and shimmering
real into like orange lately this looks
like a nice little sunset
dim you back in a little bit oh photo
booth did you get a new update look at
you guys look at you so shiny so pretty
one of the things that i do actually
really really like is when you slide up
well there we go
if you actually are going to work
they've now added access to a bunch of
different options you've got your
airplane mode you've got your wi-fi
bluetooth assisto do not disturb your
lock screen what's this oh opens up my
clock which is fantastic we got your
airdrop which i have yet to try which
i'm kind of excited your airplay so you
can watch it on your tv and most
importantly that camera because i always
get so frustrated there's always these
times when i need to take a picture and
i gotta search for my camera app let me
take a picture of you guys
the new
updated interface for the camera is is
kind of cool you can choose from the
video and you can just hit record you
got your photo you can also make it into
a square
hello instagram i'm ready for you it's
pretty cool i like it a lot what else
and messages i don't think i actually
have messages set up on here oh yes i do
so i'm going to send something to um
myself so type type type type type type
send
oh
that's really nice
i forgot that siri
i set her up to call me
my so that's what it's set up in
my in my phone so i'm gonna keep typing
to myself so you can you can see how
that looks like i'm sure a lot of you
guys noticed in your app store that all
of your apps probably needed updated
there were so many it was like every
single thing and i'm going to turn on my
automatic app updates all my apps are up
to date another thing that i do like is
here's all of your notifications i would
like to use the weather let me know what
the weather's like wednesday september
18th it is let's zoom in mostly sunny
currently at 70 degrees
my reminders get my clothes from the
dryer pay my electricity bill they've
also moved the spotlight circuit so you
don't slide all the way down because
that brings you up your notifications
you just slide a little ways it's our
ipad search effort fed for poop
nothing available well that's uh that's
ios 7 my friends let me know what you
guys think about it my initial reaction
though i posted it on vine which was
this
i was so upset because nothing was
working i'm like what is happening
hopefully none of you guys had any
issues i did see some people on twitter
complaining they've also been having a
few problems i'm also curious to see how
it is running on older iphones because
it is a little bit slower like the
animations it feels a little clunky let
me know your thoughts tell me all of the
things in the comments below and also
let me know what phone you think i
should get yeah that's it i also plan on
having a very special video for you guys
out this friday hopefully i can get it
edited in time but
uh we'll see
hey can you give me a psl but like the
thing is it's like the same how many
syllables like pumpkin spice wow pokemon
or psl can you get me on ps4